à 52 ans jean françois est atteint de la
sclérose en plaques une maladie
dégénérative qui atteint son système
nerveux
privé de ses jambes cet ancien
professeur de sport ne peut désormais
plus travailler seules ressources les
allocations à peine 1000 euros par mois
c'est quoi ce partouche au jeu peut
restreindre pour 1000 euros par mois un
budget serré pour le loyer les charges
auxquelles il faut ajouter l'entretien
du fauteuil le transport et le matériel
liées au handicap
jean françois est aussi père de trois
enfants dont deux filles ma grande fille
mon grand fils
les seuls extra qu'il s'autorise c'est
pour eux ils vivent pas avec moi donc ça
va bon aussi et des cadeaux à faire
je ne me pose pas la question pour les
enfants parce que c'est une sorcière en
2d plus plaisir
la situation de jean françois n'est pas
exceptionnel en bourgogne franche comté
quarante mille personnes vivent de
l'allocation adulte handicapé soit 900
euros par mois depuis novembre dernier
mais ce montant est toujours inférieur
au seuil de pauvreté
pour l'association des paralysés de
france cette situation ne peut plus
durer
ce qu'on réclame c'est un revenu
individuel d'existence qu'ils soient
auteurs du smig
on a des personnes qui aujourd'hui ne
vont pas changer leur fauteuil parce
qu'ils savent qu'ils vont avoir un reste
à charge et ne pourront pas le faire ou
d'autres camps des problèmes de dents et
qui vont pas pouvoir se payer
effectivement les frais dentaires
permettre à chacun de vivre une vie
digne et libre
c'est la promesse du président de la
république jean françois et les deux
millions de français en situation de
handicap espère que cet engagement sera
suivie d'effet car comme il tient à le
souligner pouvoir vivre dignement
c'est la base